so hormone
evidib and I had a solemn
Nevada convention against torture
and withholding their bodies of both
questions
to see anybody portable
hold that so
so once again
main option
just article the
here that you see it
here and there to see asylum request
outside asylum
meaning for the country to great dart hagar
there's a card
you have your sorting protection
you got the other guard kids
you are not safe in your controversy
India to station
haggar because sakajji mother
digari tegan
all the now the duchy partition
pantheir sam
the 5892 petition
hager all the nadusi
dojijo hora
questkarza meaning
akai yaeh
withholding a removal
and do see how you can mention against torture
teigaji so
just what do you some the case claim
the manda
judge on who
withholding the removal of rubik outsider
or convention against torture
they be broke outside
sometimes
sort of some
strongly on the right
it happens
but some the kids strong
you have any meaning
you should have full kiss
and I heard
you got judge
gas are the assam
the kissing
him on those are done
but for the withholding a removal of India
or for the convention against
tortured by the idea
diggity or the knowledge of benefit
hegeh from the Greek guard
toni milda um
but you do get a work permit
to see at the us
your ass are there
may the world find
saga donably
withholding
they'll take visauter
terraria que
every two years
every one year
they get a work from it
and they can live here
right all the
not the two
travel document request
we got a saga
and you can travel to see
indefinite
on Saturday
or you can travel to other countries
so this or the assam
the gsd banda
to see withholding requests
or convention
against Portuguese costs
are they another now
so the work
from rodjiga
let's get here
iris are there
but you will not be able to bring your family
just or the family abroad
hag you into the chagya
or horocrit country
I get etaniya saga day right
with holding on to see kanata saga there
if it's only you in sort of conduct petition
I got three family job
broad I get any on Saturday
sort of family activity had yet
so nobody is on the melda right
but when the family be
with holy mouths are here
you and your family did to society usa yet
once again the assamine
ld withholding a removal
what were the option
here they can mention against torture
or we both were the option
had you to see a tera saga
there come car saga there
for however long
until it's a god again
dips yet any seven t
but with these two
you do not get a green card
with asylum
you get a green card
but these are also very very good options
if you don't have a strong asylum case